my mom my dad I have a family didn't
plan I'm ever making a sequel was meant
to just be this freestanding film and I
didn't watch it again for years I'm
remembering something what was I talking
about about eight years later we're
watching 3d version of it they want to
release they wanted me to approve it so
I sat in the theater watched it as an
audience member and I suddenly said well
my story's still so unresolved somewhere
out there is my family for me it's just
about finding home it's about where did
I come from and how did I end up alone
then you are my parents still around
what is home I suffered from short-term
memory loss it runs in my family
at least I think it does you know she
has abandonment issues they haven't been
dealt with I miss him she doesn't know
where she's from she could forget Marlin
Nemo's she could be right back - lost in
the ocean not good and I didn't like
that I felt like I'd not done my job as
a writer on the first one
it's emotional it's really a sweet
journey and she meets all these
characters along the way yes she's just
looking for a sense of belonging so
that's what just started it all
you are about to find your parents and
when you do that okay
you